>>Cheryl: Research shows that if
the student's in the right mindset
and they get their sensory needs met,
they're going to be much
better learners.
So after the sensory room,
they're able to focus more,
they're able to learn easier, and
they retain more information, I find.
>>Heather: Hands to your heart space.
Take a deep breath in.
[ inhales, exhales ]
>>Patricia: The children should
be and deserve to be educated
within their district and
within their school community.
In Meriden, we have approximately
twelve hundred students
who have individualized
educational plans.
Students with vision difficulties,
language difficulties, autism.
>>Jennifer: So here at Hanover School,
we have our STARS autism program,
and STARS stands for Students and
Teachers Achieving Remarkable Success.
>>Cheryl: So River, what did we do
yesterday, what book did we read?
>>Heather: So autism presents
throughout a very broad spectrum.
A lot of times, it's a social issue.
Some of them demonstrate
behaviors because they are not able
to communicate their needs.
They may have difficulty sitting
still for a long period of time.
>>Cheryl: They need different
sensory breaks throughout the day
so they can self regulate
their feelings and emotions.
>>Heather: Take some deep breaths here.
>>Cheryl: The sensory room is probably
my most important piece of the day.
Students go to the sensory room
in order to calm their bodies
and get all the emotions out and
stabilize themselves, so they're ready
to learn and they're happy.
>>Heather: When we designed
the sensory room,
we actually took the entire room apart.
We carpeted the floor so that we
could absorb some of the sound.
We put the shades on the ceiling to
change the light, so when they walk
in that room, they feel the change.
All the students in this school go
by that room and want to go in there.
>>Cheryl: It's actually not
just for the STARS program.
It's for any student in the whole
school that might be having a tough day.
My class specifically, we
utilize the room once a day
for a thirty minute break and then once
a week, we have physical therapists
that work with our students.
>>Heather: First thing that
they do is go on the ball
and they bounce to a metronome.
>>Clap. Hold.
>>We work with the breathing
to calm them.
>>Breath in.
>>And then we move into some yoga.
>>Lion.
[ Students roar ]
>>Heather: It's really
a way to ground them
into the space before we have
them go out into the room.
>>Cheryl: All right, my friends.
We're going to do our
rotation now, okay?
>>So there's different
stations in the sensory room,
and some of my students
love specific stations.
One in particular loves the
punching bags and the ropes.
He's able to get all that anger and
frustration out, so that calms him down.
Whereas another student, I know
he needs calming movements,
so he's on the swing
going back and forth.
>>Heather: Another area in
the room is the crash pad.
You will see students that have sensory
issues bump into walls, bang their head.
So what we've created is a
safe space to crash into.
And then there's the light wall.
You could use your hands,
you could use your feet.
There's different games that
are programmed on there,
and really what you're doing is
hitting something, and getting all
that input back into your joints.
>>Teacher: Yes, good girl.
>>Heather: We also work on
balance and coordination.
The walking path works on all of those,
and that affects your vestibular
system, which is your inner ear.
And they have to right themselves,
correct their body in space.
We have ten pound slam balls.
Some students just need to come in,
pick something heavy up and throw it.
That's the essence of a sensory room.
You're putting materials in
there that are appropriate,
so a student's not throwing a chair.
And at the end when they finish with
their stations, they lay on the floor
and they're squished,
to give them more input,
so that they're prepared
to leave the room.
So everything that we do in there is
predictable, there's a set sequence.
>>Cheryl: We're all done
with sensory room.
We're going to walk back to our class.
>>Patricia: So we have
found that the impact
of the sensory room has
increased time on task,
and it has decreased negative behaviors.
So the kids are able to sit
in their seat and stay focused
for longer periods of time.
>>Teacher: What do you put
at the end of your sentence?
>>Student: Period.
>>Teacher: Good job, high five.
>>Cheryl: They're quieter and
their hands are to themselves,
and they're able to listen
to my directions.
We're here, we came from the
sensory room, we're ready to learn.
>>How does the sensory
room make you feel?
>>Student: Happy.
>>Cheryl: Nice job, Alan.